dude i want to talk about britney spears
we need we
simply have to talk about this
so for the people that haven't seen uh
one day ago britney spears posted a two
photo carousel on her instagram with the
caption free woman energy has never felt
better
and she is completely naked apart from a
long pair of white socks and she has an
emoji of a heart over her vagina
and
a flower over her nipple
and then there's another photo if you
swipe right there is another photo where
she's
kind of like
wide-legged
uh
and with the same the same emoji setup
so you can go and see this and it's got
nearly three million likes but perhaps
unsurprisingly she turned comments off
um
what's your
what's your thoughts on that answer
so there's a youtuber called alexander
grace i sent you the link to his youtube
video he was saying polygamy he's gonna
be the new i'm watching that one and um
he said it in like a fantastic way where
he said imagine if the real feminists of
the 1900s saw what was happening today
like they would they would think that
you were lying if we told them oh yeah
by the way like women are fighting to be
more sexualized than ever to like to for
free post pictures of themselves so that
millions of tens of millions of people
can see it
the real feminists of the 1900s would
think that you were joking they would
think that you were just like mocking
them
that this is like it's the sad state
where now
i especially think of like the young
women and the teenagers who who are kind
of seeing like their idols post this and
obviously we model after the people that
we look up to and it's kind of like okay
so
in this bizarre counter-intuitive way
the modern sort of feminist narrative
has
encourages women more than ever
to show off their bodies to be
promiscuous which is kind of like the
counter-intuitive aim of the 1900s
movements certainly not a linear
progression between the two dude the
thing that i [ __ ] think
we need to all apologize to her dad
and say look dad
maybe you were right you see that court
case do you see where he was basically
oh right okay so
the story seems like britney spears's
dad had control over her entire life
like
she her estate which included her back
cat log of records um i think it was
like even to do with her finances how
she could spend money it was it was
pretty severe right and it seemed a bit
sinister as well especially the way it
was portrayed in the press i don't know
the ins and outs of the court case but
it didn't seem
fantastic but also
britney's had some um
challenges mentally in the past which i
think was what had legitimated that in
the first place so anyway there was this
big back and forth and it was hashtag
free britney was going on for ages right
they wanted to give her her life back
and i don't know what the current
situation of that is i feel like she
might have got more of a liberty back
from her father but you think britney if
this is the first thing that you do
after getting if you post a fully naked
selfie twice on instagram
to prove your own sanity and the fact
that you don't need your father i'm like
i
i don't know if we were right i don't
know if we were right
save britney maybe save britney not free
britney
i think to be honest
you and i are looking at this from quite
a level-headed perspective which
isn't really the general consensus of
the modern world around us whereas okay
so we're looking at this in like a quite
critical way but i think the
overwhelming majority of people will see
this as a positive act for like feminism
and for the act of um
expressing their sexuality they'll see
like this is a confident thing like a
brave thing to do
i'm so maybe i have too much faith in
humanity but but people can let us know
in the comments right if you think that
what your opinion of this is whether
britney is
um liberating herself and
experimenting with the sovereignty of
her own body and her own social media
platform
or if this is
somebody that could do with a bit of
help and needs a phone call from a
friend like it doesn't
seem to me i would be
interested to speak to the person that
says like go brittany after that
um and it just seems like a bad pr move
as well you've just come out of a court
case where your dad had control of
everything because he was worried that
you're going to lose your head and then
you
i don't know
for some people there's no such thing as
bad people
oh yeah well i mean britney's
come on brittany it's been a while how
long was like her first single 20
probably 25 years ago or some [ __ ] but
that's another interesting thing we were
talking about this offline
um what happens when you very quickly
gain status and think about child stars
um and this is f here's an interesting
one for you man
britney spears macaulay culkin
and brett weinstein eric weinstein
jordan peterson
people at kind of the opposite ends of
life and maturity but both of which can
be just gifted global renown immediately
how the [ __ ] you supposed to deal with
that status like the human brain was not
meant to be able to receive
international acclaim and be known by
millions and millions of people
like like that
honestly that's why you see so many of
these like child celebrities with mental
breakdowns like it used to be
in quite horrifying ways to be kind of
kind of funny to the general population
i think either it was britney spears or
madonna or something like trim their
head off the hair off and everyone was
laughing about it and everything but
it's only now as more like as we were
saying like normal people are starting
to get fame and you know
you and i are branching into like the
dark territory where we're like somewhat
normal somewhat not and like we can
start to see like we haven't spoke about
this but we you must get some kind of
like hate comments every now and then it
does like mess you up sometimes because
we haven't even fathomed the power of
the internet yet and when you do read a
comment it's in my belief that it feels
exactly like a person in front of you
saying that and when we do get like a
critical comment from someone it's this
evolutionary thing inside of us that
like kicks up you know puts us into
fight or flight thinking okay if you
don't act right you'll be kicked out of
the tribe
imagine that
with 10 people that's scary imagine that
with a hundred well that's
life-threatening now imagine it was like
literally a million people
no wonder these like these guys are like
literally taking naked pictures of
themselves like hopefully they're
getting like you know what like i mean
i would love to know the
the motivation behind that that uh photo
so [ __ ] interesting but you are right
like
people
remember the insults and forget the
blessings that negativity bias is a hell
of a drug and it's everywhere but
i don't know les would not be swayed by
that les would be completely fine and he
would just
get stuck into what he's got to do next
if you enjoyed that then press here for
the best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe peace